hi everybody recently i asked you all to
tell me your most unusual perhaps
unpopular opinions about the new wheel
of time show the first five episodes
have been released as of me recording
this my goal was to get stuff that would
make me shiver that would make me angry
perhaps i'm not looking for the stuff
that's this show is good this show was
bad i have a lot of hope in you you all
all right truth be told we did this with
do it was fun but it took forever to
record um because there were a million
comments and there's actually a lot more
comments this time about wheel of time
so you'll be seeing my honest reactions
i have not looked at any of these this
will be spoilers for
probably the first four episodes i'm not
going to be talking about the books i'm
not gonna well i'll be talking a little
bit about the books but i won't be
spoiling major stuff from the books i've
only read the first couple of books so
uh don't worry about that this is just
the show i'm gonna start with twitter
because for some reason the opinions on
twitter are a little more grounded than
those on youtube parents should have
been given multiple wives to murder in
the first episode instead of just one
i love how i'm
saying twitter has the
is a little more grounded and that's our
first one honestly the dark lord that
keeps appearing in the main three's
dreams right now looks visually like a
high schooler on halloween yeah
bowzamon's kind of getting the unfair
treatment right now still sort of scary
but also like in a creepy 2005 cgi way
scorpion king kinda you know i haven't
seen it yet but i heard there's a
trollic sex scene this is what i look
forward to the most when i do finally
watch it
no trolloc sex scene wheel of time
should be kafka's metamorphosis type
story where the dragon reborn wakes up
one day as an actual dragon and has to
deal with the consequences of this now
that i think about it other than that
character being an actual dragon what
about the story would actually change
they're all just regular looking people
and then one of them's a literal dragon
they're like i have no idea who the
dragon is rosamund pike over acts most
of the time love the main title theme
but the score overall seems off a good
example is when hold on osman pike is
overacting i don't see that at all i
think there
is some overacting in the show but it's
definitely not rosman pike who i think
is giving a really steady solid
performance it would be at least twice
as good with half the budget
i still feel the constraints of a budget
in some ways you know i feel like they
could have gone bigger if they had more
of a budget the cold opened episode one
was great actually and sets up important
stuff for later on while also building
and treating cures you know i didn't
have that much trouble with the cold
opening a lot of people had did i mean
it would have been cool to see dragon
mount stuff they should have just had
billy zane play balzam on and had cgi
flames leaking from eyes and mouth as
versions
they need to do a better job at making
it clear who the dragon reborn is i
still don't have a clue yeah catherine's
right haven't watched it or read the
books i give it all a 10 out of 10. good
anya a lot of these are just like
the show is just generally bad and i
just can't really read all those there's
a you know there's a lot where it's just
like oh i don't like the show but
there's not really i can really
do with that so sorry i'm not reading a
lot of these comments the landscape of
the two rivers is too dramatic it should
be more like iowa yeah i always pictured
it being pretty boring which
leads me to think
another thing i have a major issue with
the show is all the kids when they go
out into the real world after leaving um
the two rivers they're they are clueless
and everything is so big and huge and
weird to them they feel very
world weary and wise and like when matt
and rand walk into a tarvalan it's like
kind of like any us today walking into
like uh i don't know chicago just like
oh okay cool where are we gonna eat in
the books they have no clue how to like
comprehend all of this activity all
these people everything just feels a
little too normal for me i want that
magic i want that that wonder i liked
episode one yeah hot take episode one's
the best episode so far i'm sticking to
that no time to get emotionally attached
to the characters yeah i'm i'm having
that trouble too the i said eye costumes
are not good and a lot of the
cinematography is either dull or bad
there is something a little too clean
about the whole look of the show
honestly it pulls me out of the show
sometimes you know it feels like just
maybe the lighting or the way why is it
so pristine it's so everything pops all
the colors are just popping channeling
is too much like rey using the force in
the new star wars movies too much power
too easily gained used with no drawbacks
if i were watching it without having
read the books i would say that it does
feel like there's no rules it doesn't
feel very earned like things can just
kind of happen and you have that issue
it starts to feel like you can just
get out of anything with magic okay this
one says honestly not enough focus on
rand one of the joys of the books is how
it gets bigger with more povs as the
series goes on first gradually then
being cracked wide open around books
three or four
not a show ruiner but
a missed opportunity i think it's good
that we're going to other characters but
i think it's more about capturing that
innocence you know these characters
don't really know anything and they're
really learning a lot and growing up i
wish they had kept the character's age
down i really
i'm not even aged down just like
have more innocence you know
show that they're really from a small
town they're really out of their element
and it just feels like they're way too
capable in this world they're they're
doing pretty fine you know they can
handle themselves when tom fights the
the fade in in the in the eye of the
world it feels like the end of the world
for them it feels like they are screwed
because that's like the one person
helping them get along who knew who
knows how the world works so much of it
is just trying to figure out what the
hell are they gonna do like they're way
in over their heads but in the show it
just kind of feels like that tom you
know he'll handle the fade we'll we'll
just get on how we've been getting on
and oh another thing uh anything about
woke political reasons i'm just gonna
skip because it's a show
produced for the biggest corporation in
the world it's not woke it's it's just
like literally
of its type like i don't i don't chill
just chill if you have issues with the
show great but
don't blame it on an amazon produced
show trying to be too woke the radical
politics of wheel of time
i wanted to see more death yes i wanted
to see mortith as well again i see how
it's really not that important but it
was a good scene in the book scary scene
you know it could have been a good scene
they should have just cut the menethra
in speech yeah the the speech with
marine on the on horseback a lot of
people love it i really wasn't crazy
about it they should make this running
gag with parent where he keeps
accidentally killing the people he loves
with an axe people will be crying with a
lap with laughter by the fourth or fifth
time he does it parents just like oh i'm
ready to finally use my axe again oh
just accidentally killed rand too much
real world swearing and exclamations
prefer the ones in the book yeah i don't
think that's a hot take i think a lot of
i think that a lot of people aren't
enjoying that i mean i don't like that
because it it does feel pulls me out of
the story especially with the tone
they're going for you know it doesn't
feel
right they should have cut paren aguain
and the tinkers and instead let tom sing
30 more songs maybe not let tom sing 30
more songs but i do think they could
have trimmed down the aguain parent
scenes with the tinkers well we're just
hanging out you know with the tinkers
the breaking of the world was not
poggers
i i will
agree with that i hate hate hate
moraine's shoulder pads with the heat of
a thousand raging suns
embrace the shoulder pads i'm glad it
looks so different from my mental
picture it won't be stealing the way i
pictured the books from me instead it
just adds by being a story in a format i
can share with others in a timely manner
i kind of get that because i've i've
gotten to a phase where i've accepted
like you know it's not going to be the
story i've pictured and in a way it's
kind of liberating because i go well i
like the books i can i'm going to keep
reading the books and it'll be something
different and i my image of aguain and
naive and lan and i see them still is
what i picture them in the book and
since they're so different from
their show betrayal it does feel like
different characters a different story
really rosamond henny don't really work
as moraine land for me although both
terrific actors i i will say i think
that they're my favorite part of the
show they've got good chemistry tinkers
are useless
they might be super important later on
in the books i honestly don't know
here's what i'll say it feels like the
show
just doesn't have enough confidence in
the material i think they were scared
i don't know
or
or they're just trying to make it more
of a typical tv experience i think it
would would have been kind of weird tv
but i think it would have been different
the biggest problem with this adaptation
is that it's mostly fine it's not a
garbage fire it's not a pristine perfect
adaptation it's changes even where
drastic aren't boulder dynamic it's
basically just the adaptational
equivalent of this meme
in some ways that's the hardest thing
you know it feels like a very safe
adaptation it's like they're trying to
do the very safe thing they're trying to
hit the beats that you hit in a modern
fantasy tv show it's not hitting these
excellent highs but it's also not a
total yeah like like he said a total
trash fire a total mess you can't hate
watch it
which i like to do why on god's green
earth did i read all these comments i
should ask myself that there's a goblin
intruder we've had warder butt in
episode 1 but no normal human butt
therefore we don't know for sure if that
level of butt is something only waters
can achieve or if it is regular butt
level for this sci-fi dystopia world
really asking the important questions
here i would argue that it is a uniquely
warder but what
this is so good
my opinions are popular my art isn't i
drew this instead of reading help pazuzu
knows look at this artwork
just amazing and
it's me i imagined bella much more of a
shaggy mare than what we got okay i
haven't been reading all these but there
are a surprising amount of bella
comments just about her not being enough
in the show or bella's the dragon reborn
i'm letting you know that i'm sparing
you not enough dong
i hate everything about tom's character
in the show
i love tom in the books and having him
just be an outright badass rockstar
looking guy who's just like gravely
voiced singing like nickelback songs i
don't mean to be harsh but it really did
not sit with well with me and i i didn't
feel the chemistry between the
characters nadia who's never read the
book she thought it was weird how they
just left tom with the fade in the barn
and there was such a
an emotional scene in the books in the
show it was so rushed it felt like they
just kind of forgot tom and tom's just
like fighting and they're just kind of
like see ya like we can't really help
you balzamon and the merdrol are both
hot and they should get together i wish
they had gone with even less blood gore
uh yeah feels out of place it feels
weird feels unnecessary it feels
gratuitous because it doesn't fit with
the tone you know what it feels like
feels like they're trying to say hey
this ain't a kids show accept what you
are like just embrace what you are you
don't have to be constantly trying to
say like hey we're for we're for the
grown-ups if you're gonna be the next
game of thrones
you gotta show some but with the level
of violence and the heavy subject matter
i think they could have shown some sex
scenes and i mean sex scenes too not
love scenes realistic clumsy hairy
physical sex i think the world is ready
to see a pair of banging trollics
surprising amount of uh people were
really hoping to see some trollic sex
scenes where is this coming from
apparently they have dump truck asses
i'm that's just twitter and that's not
even the majority of all right we've
been recording for an hour already god
damn it okay nearly 700 comments
on youtube which
this might kill this might actually kill
me i want them to cast a new actor for
matt every season and nobody in the cast
and crew ever addresses why there's a
new mat it's just a thing
good
call
i will i will buy it i'll say this once
more so everyone can hear let ren kiss a
troll again the trollix we have yet to
have a single braid tugging scene season
two should have an entire episode that
has no plot or dialogue just naive
tugging her braid for 55 consecutive
minutes i've never watched the show but
i think there's a significant lack of
wheels
i was weirded out by the sizzling
chemistry between paul and his mother
stop it stop no should have been an
anime guy should shouldn't have been an
anime all along that's the real question
please let me know in the comments the
real dragon were born were the friends
we made along the way this is the
attitude i want to see no more fighting
about if the show's good or bad ran
should be taller if he's not the tallest
object in the known universe is this
really even the wheel of time i agree
with that i would have preferred a
stormlight archive adaptation but this
works too i guess that's the the best
kind of critique of a show you know
would have liked it if it was another
show you know what is you know what
would save the series ed sheeran singing
in a campfire
i see you good joke the show feels like
fan fiction don't know if it's an
unpopular opinion that's a
lot but a lot of people are saying that
come on if your review of the tv show
boils down to it's not like the books
you have no business trying to rate or
review things people can review things
however they want i think a lot of
people make the mistake of seeing flaws
in the show
and going it's bad because it's not like
the book i laughed at lan when he pulled
his shirt open when he was grieving at
the funeral i know they were going for
stoic but it just felt silly i really
was into that scene but yeah when he
opened his shirt it felt it just broke
me out of the immersion it was like
rest of the scene was great overall
episode 5 to me was pretty
dull i think matt taking the dagger is
the best thing he ever did that ruby is
very beautiful whatever take that dagger
looks nice it goes to show even with
decent production value you can't make a
good show from a [ __ ] book
boo
i want a troll subplot with two gay
troll husbands who learn to speak and
love and they just want to be free see
what where is this coming from i mean
great but
what
okay i don't like sand it's rough and
coarse and it gets everywhere i'm doing
this for every horrible opinion sections
from now on and you can't stop me jake
you'll fail over and over just like your
wi-fi router
how do you know about that about my
wi-fi router i'm afraid they will have a
daniel green camp all caps daniel green
cameo in the second season i fear the
goblin as should we all the daniel turns
into booktube
wouldn't that be great just have daniel
green
just do what ed sheeran did in game of
thrones just have him shoot his own
stuff on his green screen and just like
patch him into the background somewhere
just like standing there let's make it
happen guys yes i'm here for these
videos genius of our time
me that's like a nugget of love in the
in the midst of an ocean of
pain i hated the way they gave rand
mjolnir just like that seemed like a
plot to you've been you commented like
50 times moraine and lan are sizzling
with that sexual chemistry stop it just
because game of thrones made lizard
brain greedy politics popular doesn't
mean every show has to copy it childhood
wonder can be marketably successful if
done right there's
childhood wonder
this is what i'm getting at the
childhood wonder is gone
whoa what what did i do there are not
enough scenes with matt and ryan kissing
again a lot of these comments too about
matt and rand they should chop maureen's
head off on season finale
where is this coming from i would like
to see just how many times moraine will
be stabbed by something and then healed
from it immediately after that's a
problem it's a problem just when you
feel like a character is invincible need
to reshoot tom's performance with will
ferrell playing jazz flute and rocking a
huge mustache will ferrell is tom i
would actually buy that that'd be pretty
sweet i think joker was better than
parasite and deserve to win the oscar
you are in the wrong comment section my
friend i don't have any spicy takes but
i just want to be in the video this
worked for someone last time and i hope
it does work for me it worked you're in
the video i don't like looking at rand
these are pretty harsh robert time made
a good words that's the kind of comment
i love to see thank you well that has
been insightful
maybe
you all are really testing me and it's
it's a been an interesting process but i
appreciate you regardless i'm sorry i
couldn't get to all of your comments i
promise you i read every single comment
even though i probably should not have
thank you for watching i will see you
all soon go ahead and have a lovely week